[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
meine kinder essen ja wirklich gerne
einst als kind habe ich auch gerne eis
gegessen vor allem bei unserer nachbarin
da gab es nämlich immer dieses sandwich
eis also es war immer so meine mama geht
immer geschneidert und hosen gekürzt und
hat mich dann immer eben zu den nachbarn
geschickt zum hose zurückgeben oder zur
bluse wieder abgeben
und da war eine nachbarin es war nicht
frau mag und die hat mir früher immer
dieses sandwich eis gegeben diese
waffeln und dazwischen dieses kraft
fürst pückler eis heißt es mit erdbeere
vanille und schoko und meine kids die
mögen auch ganz gerne sandwiches heute
machen wir das selber wir machen auch
die waffel selber da habe ich mir
überlegt machen wir einfach waffeln aus
dem waffeleisen und weil ich alles
ziemlich lecker finde geht es heute bei
seinen trips kühn ich sage ich mal kurz
die zutaten für den waffelteig für den
waffelteig verwende ich zehn oreo kekse
180 gramm mehl 70 gramm kakaopulver
einen teelöffel backpulver und viertel
teelöffel natron etwas salz 100 gramm
zucker 80 gramm flüssige butter zweier
etwas verpasst er in schwarz 450 gramm
butter milch und von den extrakt nämlich
zuerst den euro könnte natürlich auch
ganz normale andere schokokekse nehmen
oder diese auch weglassen
aber ich denke die geben dem ganzen noch
mal richtig guten geschmack jetzt hier
einfach öffnen und die creme auskratzen
der kriegswirren zerkleinert und die
creme die gebe ich jetzt zur botschaft
gibt sich nämlich auch
ich nehme sie jetzt auseinander und
zerkleinerte so weil sich die kekse ohne
die creme wirklich besser zerkleinern
lassen wenn ihr aber einem hochleistungs
mixa habt und der alles schön
pulverisiert könnte es natürlich auch
einfach zusammen lassen kommt ja alles
gemeinsam
die butter einfach nur mit der creme
schmelzen und dann einfach die kekse
schönbein verkleinern
jetzt kommen alle trockenen zutaten
einfach in eine rührschüssel also mehl
zucker tricks brösel und kakao salz
backpulver und natron kurz berühren
jetzt kommen hier die flüssigen zutaten
dazu also die mutter mit der creme
dies ist auch schon flüssig geworden
kommen die eier
echt super einfacher tag also waffelteig
und muffins teil
die gehört so zu den einfach den reigen
einfach mit dem löffel verrühren oder
mit dem handrührgerät den extrakt und
buttermilch und die putschisten sich
jetzt einfach nach und nach dazu
und wenn ihr möchtet dass die waffeln
fast dunkel werden mit der orion kekse
dann könnte jetzt noch verpasst in
schwarz
das habe ich das waffeleisen schon
erwärmt es werden ganz normal waffeln
ausgebacken je nachdem was wir von ihr
habt kurz vorher fetten dann genügend
teig rein aber bei mir werden sie jetzt
weniger ware finden weil es einfach
belgische die kehrwoche sind
das habe ich vier dicke waffeln gebacken
weil sie nicht der schoko oder auch wenn
seit ist das gar nicht schlimm dann
macht ihr einfach helle waffen da gibt
es ja bereits ein rezept auf meinem blog
die backe ich jetzt auch noch denn dann
gibt es zwei verschiedene varianten
ich lasse ich hier mal schön
nebeneinander abkühlen und sobald sie
kalt sind können dass sie auch stapeln
wenn ihr sie direkt stapel nach dem
backen werden seien noch weich und
matschig für mich zu finden
jetzt sind alle waffeln gebacken und
abgekühlt jetzt werden sie bereits
gefüllt also ihr seht ein richtig cooles
schnelles rezept ich nehme jetzt für die
orior waffen
die haben wir gestern noch beim bauern
klaus wallbaum schröder kult in
reilingen richtig schöne frische erbsen
und die halten auch echt ewig weil sie
eben am tag ganz früh morgens ganz
frisch gepflückt werden die jetzt in
scheiben schneiden
[Musik]
es brauchte jeweils zwei ecken für ein
sandwich 1 und nehmt euch einfach jetzt
ein eis das mache ich jetzt nicht selber
denn selbst gemachtes eis schmilzt immer
schneller
ich habe ich aber ein konditor es gibt
bei uns beim globus schmeckt auch
richtig gut was hat euch nicht so ganz
lange haltbar wie die aus der
tiefkühltruhe drei wochen sind einfach
keine konservierungsstoffe drin
echt gut und das jetzt in eine ecke
rheinstraße
hier lege ich jetzt die erdbeben noch
rein
die dürften reichen in so einem system
rausgucken jetzt sei es auch unter dem
deckel damit die erdbeeren schön haften
so stelle ich es jetzt in den
gefrierschrank damit es noch mal fest
werden kann
jetzt wird es ein bisschen geschmolzen
dann kann ich die ränder noch mal ein
bisschen glatt streichen und so ist im
prinzip schon das erste bio eis fertig
und die helle variante die für mich ein
bisschen anders dann nehme ich entweder
erdbeereis oder pistazien oder zitrone
und alle land kommen dann streute das
machen jetzt auch noch zusammen
murat chemie bereich ja ich bin also ich
hab hier sandwiches gemacht mit waffeln
das eine story etwas andere ist mir zu
streuseln ok schärfe ich kann's auch
halbieren sage ich mir gedacht ich habe
ich habe noch mehr aber ich dachte dass
eine komplette zwei wünsche ein augen
nur die erdbeeren vertragen werden es
wäre auch nicht schlecht
das ist eine coole idee auch mal für so
eine fastfoodkette eigentlich die
ideengeber für irgendjemanden welches
gekauft weil es dann noch selber machen
zu den mafia boss waffeln deluxe kann
ich ein eis beißen natürlich das problem
beschreibt ein bischen reis oder milch
ein bisschen auftauen lassen ein
bisschen auftragen lassen mag ebenso
gern eins also so ganz kalt aber ich
warte nicht fest ich meine wir haben
halt ein belgisches waffeleisen diese
dicken waffeln
ich denke die meisten die zu den waffen
dann halt auch so ein dünneres ist nicht
so hoch sondern vielleicht nur so dass
ich glaube die kunst bei dem liegt das
an dem es ist ja du musst das machen wir
eigentlich habe ich übrigens den rand
noch im cookies getaucht also einfach
nur ich finds halt nicht schön
eine coole art und weise ich finde ist
auch eine coole anweisung schon waffe
laden hat da gibt es diese machen lehnt
machen wenn eine coole idee für euch das
mit eis zu machen richtig kombiniert
geschichte nennt jetzt dann bitte ich
finds aber cool
doch demnächst mal unsere freundin die
grillparty mit dass antrat und kümmert
das machen wir einfach mitnehmen ja ja
machen oder wenn ihr einfach übrig
gebliebene waffeln habt kann man als
kohlereste fangen also probiert gerne
aus gerne auch andere ausführungen mit
smart efficiency auch ziemlich cool oder
getrocknete früchte vorher pulverisieren
und dann die hieraus eine coole art und
weise auch verpackungsmüll zu sparen
hier so essen ohne backen macht es nach
den rezepten anleitung findet ihr auf
sadismus blog.de danke jungs probieren
zweites geschäft ist wirklich viel
probieren ja ja wir arbeiten jetzt
weiter ein bisschen worden und 38 schon
zum vater erstens kann auch nicht jeder
banken